[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
so why is it that we support ukraine in
this war or put it another way why are
we against russia let's be clear almost
all media outlets in the west including
your favorite one visualpolitik take it
for granted that putin is the bad guy
and zelensky is the good gang side note
in case someone is going to put it in
the comments we have never said that
ukraine is a paradise on earth what's
more we have a long list of videos which
we have outlined the corruption and all
the shameful behavior of ukrainian
politicians even when we give a
visualpolitik 2021 award to vladimir
zelinski we made it very clear that we
can't even guarantee that this man
doesn't have some corruption scandal
lurking in his past in any case all of
our videos start from the premise that
the invasion of ukraine is barbaric in
every sense of the word we start from
the premise that both europe the united
states along with liberal democracies
around the world must unite to stop
putin we've talked about trade sanctions
rearmament in europe and armed shipments
to ukraine that is the basis of all of
our analysis here on visualpolitik and
many of you will ask why is there really
no argument to defend putin's position
what if reality were more complex than a
story of good guys and bad guys
well the truth is there are legitimate
arguments to defend putin's actions and
no we're not going to talk about
pro-russian propagandists nor are we
going to talk about some wannabe
influencer trying to get famous there
are some in every country we are going
to talk about top political analysts who
would not agree with us at all people
with enormous academic and political
prestige mainly this gentleman you see
here john merchamer he has a lecture
entitled why ukraine is the west's fault
which has already accumulated more than
27 million views on youtube so take that
for all the people that say that youtube
is only for light content well in this
video we're going to unpack many of the
main theories that in one way or another
criticize the actions of the west and in
their own way justify putin's action as
you can imagine there is a lot of
editorial positioning in this video and
naturally there are many things you can
discuss in the comments all we ask is
that you be respectful because the
questions we are asking today are what
are the main anti-nato theories in this
ukrainian war why do we think that they
are wrong what do we think are the
biggest myths of the ukrainian invasion
today we're going to answer all of these
questions but first let's look at some
history
[Music]
idealism versus real politics
i'm sure many of you have seen john
merchamer's talk if you have not seen it
we'll leave you the link in the
description the first thing we have to
understand is that this man represents a
very specific ideology of international
relations he is one of the main
representatives of the so-called
political realism and what do these
so-called realists argue
according to their theory the world is
an anarchy where each state is governed
by its own interests unlike liberals
realists believe that it is almost
impossible to achieve cooperation
between states on the basis of ethical
principles relations are based on a
zero-sum game where some win and others
lose logically it follows that in such
anarchy the law of might is right
prevails well through this lens russia
is responding to nato's expansion which
poses an existential threat to its
security take a look at this map
the question that should be asked here
is is it really possible to speak of
nato expansion the truth is that it's
not
[Applause]
there is a difference between expanding
an organization that is trying to get
other states to enter or simply opening
the door to whoever wants to enter at
the moment nato has not forced any
member country to join the union if it
had austria and ireland would have been
members for many many years in reality
it is the member countries themselves
that have decided to join we are talking
about democratic governments that have
applied for membership for security
reasons nato has simply accepted them in
any case many realists would say okay be
that as it may the fact that so many of
russia's neighbors are entering into a
military alliance that antagonizes
moscow is a threat and this is where the
argument that many of you have heard ad
nauseam these days comes in the united
states would not tolerate mexico or
canada entering into a military alliance
led by china or russia and this is where
we get into hypotheticals what would
happen if mexico were to enter into a
military alliance led by china is it
clear that washington would try to
prevent it the question is would they go
so far as to invade well there was one
small president cuba
[Music]
cuba is right beside the united states
for decades cuba was within the soviet
orbit they even starred in the famous
missile crisis in 1962. in that case the
soviet union was placing ballistic
missiles in cuba and that was solved
diplomatically since then it's clear
that relations between washington and
havana have been anything but friendly
but so far we have never seen the us
militarily invade the island not even
after the dissolution of the ussr
however in this case everything starts
with this fact
nato welcomes ukraine and georgia's
euro-atlantic aspirations for membership
in nato we agreed today that these
countries will become members of nato
nato declaration on the bucharest summit
2008. that's right nato was opening its
doors to ukraine and yes this was a
provocation to russia the question is is
it really reasonable to think ukraine
was going to join we have discussed this
several times on visualpolitik and the
answer is no
to begin with the majority of its
population was against it in 2010 51 of
ukrainians said no to nato in order to
avoid provoking russia but not only that
as we have already discussed in several
visual politic videos ukraine's military
did not meet any of the union standards
starting to the fact that it was worn
down by years of corruption remember
that in 2014 during the invasion of
crimea they didn't even have uniforms to
clothe the soldiers put another way nato
was risking a lot and gaining very
little and i know what many of you are
thinking if nato was not sure that
ukraine was going to join why did they
make the statement why provoke russia
well yes that is a totally valid
argument and here mr merscherler is
absolutely right in fact the solution he
proposed to avoid the war we are
witnessing today was very realistic
check this out my view is we should
create a neutral ukraine which is a
buffer state between nato and russia of
course this is a very legitimate
position and it is difficult to refute
it especially in the year when this talk
was given back in 2015 at that time it
was easy to think that putin was merely
seeking the neutrality of ukraine and
nothing more even marshmallow himself
thought so see for yourselves if they
were to try and create a greater russia
by invading ukraine and by invading the
baltic states they'd be jumping into the
briar patch in fact again if you want to
wreck russia what you should do is tell
them to try and create a greater russia
however reality has shattered even the
most realistic thesis putin has done
exactly what no one expected tried to
take over all of ukraine starting with
keeve
let's recap what happened since then
ukrainian war broke out in 2014. that
year ukraine was not asking for nato
membership by a long shot in fact what
sparked putin's ire was this
eu ukrainian association agreement to
sign or not to sign exactly we are
talking about a trade agreement with the
european union an agreement that sparked
protests against the pro-russian
government in kiev many want us to think
that these protests were a u.s sponsored
coup d'etat but let's be clear ukraine
already had a huge pro-european
population in 2014 and a good proportion
of this population lived in the capital
in other words it is quite realistic to
think that many of these ukrainians who
with or without us help rose up against
their government in other words there
was no need for any u.s intervention to
explain this phenomenon but remember it
was not even about ukraine's entry into
the european union and some will say
seriously grant but signing a free trade
agreement with europe basically means
joining nato right well not really just
take the examples of austria ireland
finland and sweden all of them are full
members of the european union not one of
those four countries is a member of nato
and until this year neither sweden nor
finland were considering joining put
another way at no point are we saying
that ukraine had nuclear warheads
pointed at russia all of russia's
hostilities started over a trade deal
and remember that this was not the first
time russia has had conflicts with
ukraine
[Music]
basically every time ukrainians have
elected governments that were not to the
kremlin's liking all of europe has had
problems with russian gas supplies we
saw this in 2005 and in 2008 but another
way unleashing putin's wrath is actually
pretty easy now the question we should
be asking ourselves ed would a free
trade agreement with europe really
represent an existential crisis for
russia and mershmir's answer is this the
only thing that matters is what vladimir
putin thinks and if putin and his
lieutenants think it's an existential
threat we ought to be very careful in
dealing with him the question now then
is is this the right approach it
certainly makes a lot of sense now if we
assume this we will have to assume that
ukraine is not a sovereign state neither
ukraine nor any small country this is no
straw man argument it is acknowledged by
merchmeyer himself
[Music]
i fully understand
why the ukrainians want to join the west
but the fact is the russians find that
unacceptable and the russians are much
more powerful than the ukrainians in
other words might makes right under this
principle ukraine would have to accept
any conditions from russia we are not
only talking about military neutrality
but also about trade agreements and even
governments and i know what many of you
will think this is how the world works
it is sad but it's also the reality and
yeah you might be right but be very
clear about one thing assuming this
position implies accepting that there
are countries destined to be colonies
that is we are talking about 40 million
ukrainians to not be able to choose the
political party they want in government
negotiate the trade agreements they want
and live under their own conditions this
is not being neutral it is accepting to
have no sovereignty and to be a colony
of moscow it means accepting that the
west cannot choose its trade partners
either all to avoid unleashing russia's
wrath and the question here is is it
realistic for russia to think that
ukraine and the west will avoid these
conditions
in the case of ukraine we have already
seen that they will not is the
ukrainians themselves who have decided
to put up a fight even before they had
the strong support of nato remember that
up until february 2022 nato had only
sent a few javelin missile launchers but
was not even allowing them to be used on
the battlefield more importantly is it
realistic to think that putin was going
to stop with ukraine why wouldn't he
also go after other countries that are
also considered an existential threat
for example the baltics russia has
already launched attacks on countries
like estonia even after it joined nato
there was a 2007 cyber attack in other
words if the world is an anarchy where
mike makes right which side is stronger
russia or the united states why should
the united states and europe bow to the
interests of their antagonist
[Music]
old very old ideas
let's take a look at another lecture
that has also been broadcast ad nauseam
in the hispanic world in this case we
are talking about a talk by jose antonio
zorella who is a spanish diplomat to
summarize his talk the united states has
been preventing russia and europe from
having good relations for decades well
pay attention now because we are going
to really have to go a way back in time
a long way back we are going to dust off
one of the oldest theories in
geopolitics the geographic pivot theory
of history this theory was created by
the geographer halford machinder in 1904
and it reads as follows
who rules east europe commands the
heartland who rules the heartland
commands the world island who rules the
world island commands the world halford
machinder i know what is the heart of
the earth well pay attention to this map
what you see shaded in red is what
makender calls the heart of the earth
you can also find it mentioned in some
books as the geographic pivot according
to mckinder whoever dominates this
terrain dominates most of the world's
natural resources and communications
that means that if someone were to
dominate russia and eastern europe
including a good chunk of germany he or
she would dominate the world and that is
why the united states would want to
avoid a german-russian alliance at all
costs the problem is that this theory
may have had some validity in 1904 today
the world is very different if there
were a pivot point in the world today it
would probably be in southeast asia or
asia pacific in mckinder's time asia was
not as important as it is today most
asian countries were european colonies
natural resources if we have to talk
about resources today the middle east is
of fundamental importance however at the
beginning of the 20th century oil was
nowhere near as important as it is these
days in other words mackinder's theories
are totally outdated today but speaking
of outdated theories there are many who
claim that ukraine is dusting off other
theories that seem to have gone out of
fashion forever yes let's answer the
question that many of you have asked us
in a thousand and one comments
[Music]
is ukraine a nazi country
is ukraine a nazi country you have heard
it ad nauseam russian propaganda never
tires of repeating that they want to
denazify ukraine and the truth is that
it is not only russian propaganda many
intellectuals in the west are convinced
that putin is partially right check this
out
republica independent ukrainian
protection
this gentleman is a spanish
ex-ambassador in principle he has
nothing to do with russian propagandists
and the truth is he is right in fact if
you watch some of putin's speeches you
will see that he alludes to the alleged
banderas well these are the followers of
stefan bandera one of the fathers of
ukrainian nationalism during the 1940s
bandera collaborated with the nazis
during the invasion of ukraine this man
was responsible for ethnic cleansing and
all kinds of human rights violations
however many ukrainians consider him a
national hero in fact he received the
posthumous title of hero of ukraine in
2010. interestingly this title was given
to him by pro-russian president viktor
yanukovych
fortunately or unfortunately history is
full of such characters and many of them
are elevated to the pedestals because
the enemy of my enemy is my friend in
other words at the height of stalin's
purges during the famines provoked by
russia to punish ukraine and the
holodomor many ukrainians threw
themselves into the arms of the germans
and not only ukrainians finland also
allied itself with the third reich
during its war against russia sweden
which remained neutral during world war
ii allowed the germans to cross its
territory and even collaborated with the
nazi army does this mean that sweden or
finland are nazi countries today
obviously not and even more so in the
case of ukraine if you study their
history throughout the 20th century you
will understand that they have had all
kinds of alliances and all of them have
gone wrong
in any case political figures change and
redefine themselves if not just ask
venezuelans the figure of simon bolivar
has been extolled as a hero of 21st
century socialism despite the fact that
bolivar was a bourgeoisie at the time
criticized by marx himself the reality
is that today unlike other countries
such as greece ukraine has no nazi party
in its parliament as you can imagine in
a country of more than 40 million
inhabitants there are groups with
ideologies of all kinds and yes it is
true there are battalions within the
ukrainian army that do have neo-nazi
ideology for example some units of the
famous azov battalion the question is
does anyone really expect that in the
middle of an invasion the army would
reject soldiers because of their
ideology
[Music]
i think we all understand that ukraine
at the moment is ready to recruit anyone
who wants to go to the front to fight to
use this as an argument to prove that
the whole country is under a nazi regime
is akin to living in a parallel universe
so at this point it's time for a debate
do you think there are strong arguments
to justify russia's invasion of ukraine
to what extent do you think nato should
engage with ukraine should they continue
to send weapons what does the us or nato
gain by weakening russia you can leave
your answers in the comments below and
please prove once again that the
visualpolitik community is the most
respectful and civilized of all discuss
with respect and considered arguments
and please don't make too much fun of my
teeth as always remember that we
continue to release new videos every
week so subscribe to this channel and
hit the little bell button down there so
you don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it so we know and
i'll see you next time
[Music]